philippe béchade bonjour bonjour merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation ce
matin pour parler de ce sommet européen
qui débute aujourd'hui avec au centre
des discussions la crise de l'énergie
peut-être pour commencer pourquoi cette
hausse des prix partout en europe
comment l'expliqué aujourd'hui
sont multiples
l'éléphant dans le corridor pour
l'instant c'est le prix du gaz puisqu'il
est en hausse de 46% depuis les années
on voit également que le prix du charbon
fortement progressé alors surtout en
chine un petit peu moins en europe mais
en europe c'est quand même à un facteur
important pour des pays comme la pologne
l'allemagne avec ses centrales au
charbon
du mecklenburg
hausse du pétrole donc tout le monde le
sait depuis un an
il a doublé enfin par rapport à octobre
dernier d'ailleurs on battait hier soir
un nouveau record de 7 ans aussi bien à
londres qu'à new york et puis il ya bien
sûr les fameux crédits carbone puisque
l'europe a imposé dans le cadre des
mesures de réduction des émissions de
co2 donc
un objectif
de 2 55% déjà les émissions d'ici 2030
pour parvenir à la neutralité carbone
d'ici
2050 mais déjà ses 55 % de réduction
oblige à faire des efforts très
importants
pour réduire les émissions dès
aujourd'hui et comme il y à une reprise
post crise pandémique qui est peut-être
plus forte qu'espéré on a une demande
une demande beaucoup plus importante
alors que l'europe finalement n'a pas
anticipé est l'un des problèmes que l'on
cite c'est que nos réserves de gaz par
exemple au lieu d'être à 90 % avant les
fêtes à deux mois de la période la plus
froide on est actuellement qu'à 70%
alors on va pas manquer de gaz même à
70% de réserve mais si on voulait les
reconstituer dès maintenant et elle est
remontée à la norme classique le gaz
flamberait encore beaucoup plus donc on
est obligé aujourd'hui
soit d'envisager de réduire les taxes
sur les carburants sur le gaz soit le
sort qu'on révise à la baisse nos
objectifs de neutralité carbone
peut-être les mettre entre parenthèses
quelques mois mais ça les allemands ils
n'en veulent pas et la russie s'était
d'ailleurs dit dites prêtes à intervenir
pour stabiliser les prix du gaz en
europe parce que cela voudrait dire
qu'il suffirait juste de nouveaux
contrats de livraison pour stabiliser la
situation et faire baisser les prix de
l'énergie aujourd'hui en europe
ah oui ça c'est l'impact mécanique et
psychologique serait serait il immédiat
on abord parce qu il y à un gazoduc
c'était nord stream et qui est
maintenant opérationnel mais qui reste
pour l'instant fermé pour des raisons
politiques il suffira de dire on
augmente les livraisons de gaz ne serait
ce que 2 5% et et north et permettrait
de faire beaucoup plus mais il suffirait
de dire quand on augmente les
approvisionnements de 5% pour ferrer
immédiatement rechuter le puits de gaz
le gaz la planète n'en manque pas ça
c'est une des ressources d'ailleurs dont
on est à deux pas certain que même d'ici
2100 il n'y a aucun souci
il ya des gisements
gigantesque au qatar notamment puisque
là c'est là qu'il ya un pro am le plus
grand projet au monde
2010 faction du gaz a mené par technique
énergie et un partenaire japonais
rien que ce que annexes ses capacités
supplémentaires provenant du qatar ça
devrait permettre de faire face donc là
c'est moi c'est un blocage politique
finalement
instant ça ressemble effectivement à un
blocage politique on sait que les
américains sont vent debout contre north
stream 2 parce que du coup et bien leur
producteur texan ou dakota du nord vient
perdrait finalement a débouché pour pour
du gaz liquéfié
les états unis donc depuis 4 ou 5 ans
ont changé de doctrine aujourd'hui son
prêt à exporter de l'énergie et pourquoi
le gaz pas parce que justement de gaz
quelques paris il y en a trop on va
parler du gaz sur l'essence maintenant
que peut faire l'europe parce que les
pays vont discuter de propositions
qu'ils ont appelé la boîte à outil
qu'est ce qu'il ya comme comme
proposition pour les sens très
concrètement pour les consommateurs
alors
le problème c'est que chaque pays a un
petit peu sa vision
la france
l'espagne l'italie pencherait évidemment
pour une baisse des taxes puisque ce
sont les plus élevés d'europe on
pourrait presque dire au monde
pendant que le litre de
gasoil aujourd'hui streit plus très loin
maintenant de la soixante le litre c'est
un euro au luxembourg voilà donc la
carte pays qui taxent plus c'est c'est
la suisse voilà mais les suisses ça ça
n'affecte pas leur faire moi donc
réduire les taxes parce que c'est là la
part prépondérante du prix d'un litre
les allemands eux
seraient pas contre mais attention les
allemands eux pensent que
le pic des prix actuels et les
transitoires donc est ce que c est ce
que ça vaudrait la peine de modifier nos
règlements européens pour quelque chose
qui est transitoire est ce qu'on va
tenir encore quelques semaines et puis
ben il vante éventuellement envisager
des systèmes comme des chèques pour
aider les plus
les plus impactés les plus pénalisées
par la hausse des carburants ça c'est un
peu la piste française aussi un
cessez-le-feu et des intérieurs thierry
breton à à propos de la fille str
française pourquoi les prix en france
sont les plus sont parmi les plus élevés
abbas et l'empilement des taxes si
l'empilement des taxes
si toutes les taxes la tpp cetera la tva
sur je ne sais quelle
je sais plus quelle est la partie
additionnelle que l'on doit justement à
l'europe et pour la réduction des
émissions de co2 va pas choix qu'il ya
une taxe écologique et accule halde
enfin on arrive à 55 % du prix d'un vin
du prix d'un litre qui correspond
effectivement à des taxes voilà donc si
on veut réduire le prix de l'essence
évidemment c'est pas en supprimant les
deux centimes de marge du distributeur
que ça aura un impact à
edouard leclerc michel-edouard leclerc
lui a parlé de le vendre à prix coûtant
si on vend à prix goûte on ajuste réduit
de 2 200 le prix d'un litre donc c'est
pas c'est pas ça qui qui va évidemment
faire bouger les choses quand on entend
dire que il faut matraquer les
distributeurs qui s'en mettent plein les
poches
2 centimes sur un 60 fin bon c'est
ridicule c'est bien le problème problème
vient des taxes sachant que le carburant
lui-même aujourd'hui représente même pas
50 centimes assurent les associations de
compagnies merci beaucoup philippe
béchade pour voter la rage ce matin sur
rtl france je le rappelle vous êtes
rédacteur en chef de la bourse au
quotidien